what I'll put up this is dr. John
Bologna with Ramsey Network dude we are
back with Miss Erica young the preferred
Ramsey coach
we're digging in and it's exciting I'm
glad to get to eavesdrop into this
conversation that I get to learn from
this exciting guy to have you back okay
so you've been a Ramsey preferred coach
for years you've had your own coach
you've had your own debt journey you did
it with your husband together you're a
former engineer now you're a person who
gets in the messiness of people's lives
so walk me through what brings somebody
to your chair and what goes through your
head when you're sitting down there
working with somebody yeah so when
people come to me yes like you said at
the end of the rope when they feel like
they've done all they can the money has
run out there they think that their
options are limited and my whole goal in
that initial conversation is to
understand what true options they have
that they are not seeing so usually we
have these blind spots and emotionally
people get tuned in on this one thing I
can't get any more debt I don't know how
to pay my bills my kids are you know
have all these needs and you know I
don't know what my future looks like and
they have all these questions concerns
and they can not visually see clearly
the big picture and I get a chance to
from the outside looking in say yeah but
have you thought about this have you
thought about this have you thought
about this so I love looking for options
I love helping them to see the bigger
picture and potentially shift the
conversation from lack of hope to what
about this and bringing in some hope and
some ideas for them to consider that's
the fun part
so you take it from a math problem yeah
yes to a ecosystem problem yeah
absolutely so when I was working on my
doctorate and I was seeing counseling
clients it was my experience that they
would come in in session one session two
I mean they would tell me their craziest
stuff about their sex lives they would
tell me stuff about past traumas and
they did not want to talk about money
yeah and because I had listened to the
old Dave Ramsey tapes when I was a kid
yeah I would ask him like tell me what
your financial position is what kind of
debt you have it I'm just rying to get a
picture their life yeah anyone talk
about it right they would they would put
anything else out there they want to
talk about
yeah is that your experience they know
they're coming to me for financial
health okay so they're past that okay
the point it is it is difficult
sometimes for people to open up and
that's why I share I've been there
I don't hesitate to let them know that
I've had issues with my money I don't
hesitate to let them know that sometimes
even today my husband and I had disagree
right I let them know that you know what
phase of life were in with our with our
kids and and what we're going through
like I make it real that like I'm a real
person like this is not about you know
being super technical and being buttoned
up and all that like I want them to
understand that they can talk to me so
really sometimes that initial session is
about building rapport helping them feel
comfortable breaking down walls and and
finding some sweet spots and what's
really going on and and sure they'll
tell me about their kids and their
family that's where I begin because if
they can we can get on to some of those
soft spots so it makes them open up a
little bit more what's a situation when
you're meeting with somebody you find
yourself it makes you nervous yeah or
that you go sometimes that happens when
I can already tell that they have
marital issues and that's not my area of
expertise you know I'm so I'm looking
for some of those outliers where they
might need someone else in addition to
me or prior to come in to work with me
so if they're needing a CPA if they're
needing a marriage account so I ask
those questions I'll be pointed do you
have a counselor you know is your is
your child you know seeing a counselor
is this something as a part of your life
right now be since you're seeking help
let's make sure you're getting the right
help right and then do they you know
have a financial planner if they're
having some questions that are leading
in that direction because that's not my
area of specialty so I want to make
certain that they're in the right place
and that they're getting the help that
they need and if I can help them
fabulous let's move forward so if you
were to to the millions of people out
here there's not millions of you but I
just say that because that makes me feel
better how what does a signal somebody
knows when they're over their head yeah
well usually they have no more credit
because they've been using credit and
they're like I've got you know things
nowhere else there's nowhere else to go
somebody has lost a job there was some
type of medical event somebody had a
baby
life change causes people to wake up and
that's a good thing so sometimes people
are very scared of it and and I look at
fear and anxiety in terms of you know
what's really going on and how can we
expand and say okay now that you know
right what action are you taking now
that you know what what are you going to
do with that information I don't the
fear
let's allow it to wake you up versus
shut you down and most of the time
people will just shut down and retreat
and cower and so I want to empower them
and say well it's a good thing you found
out that's right and now what are we
going to do how can we take an action
and you don't have to do this by
yourself and I don't even go for this
thing you can't do this bike yeah most
the time we can't right I don't I can't
I don't know many people that have been
successful or will struggle through yeah
and I mean then we're the walking
wounded right so how do we you know do
this in a way that is healthy productive
and it takes us to where we really want
to be so we're in the middle of I mean
there's just so many through through
ways to say this but we don't have a
playbook for 40-plus million people out
of work yeah we don't have a playbook
for you know in July the is the
government checks that are coming are
are done yeah and we happen to be an
election cycle right and we don't have a
playbook for this moment in history and
you you said earlier fear anxiety those
are often just signals that something's
out of whack in your life sure what have
you seen over the last 30 days 60 days
and your practice in the hearts and
minds of folks calling yeah yeah well at
first people were fairly optimistic and
they said well we don't know what's
really going on I think we're gonna be
okay the companies we're telling them
they're gonna be okay the layouts began
to come a little bit midstream it took a
couple weeks for people to realize I'm
not gonna be able to go back to work or
what I'm finding now is a lot of people
they're taking pay cuts something has
shifted with their income even though
they still have a job right and and I'm
telling people to just be cautious a
little bit because that can continue to
happen for a while that may be a season
that we're in and you need to really be
on top of your budget then they're
you're right we don't have a playbook
yeah
but a lot of people who already had a
budget know how to use it mm-hmm and
they know how to flip those numbers and
realize that there's a lot of things
that you know during quarantine you
didn't utilize personal care not a whole
lot of dining out some people didn't
have child care gas went extremely down
I mean there's a lot of things that have
been reduced and if you pay attention
like entertainment nobody to go to the
movies so there are a lot of things that
came out of the budget and you'll see
that if you already had a plan so
there's been a range of emotions people
you know the anxiety is actually growing
versus going down even though people are
opening up the states are opening up and
I think it's something that we have to
pay attention to in your personal
economy in your house
what's shifting what can you control
what can't you control and where do you
need to seek some help
so coaches are by nature optimistic
right they go into situations and they
say like I think we can win this game
yeah otherwise it would be a coach yeah
you're right every game we're gonna lose
guys right what people often don't get
to see is the what I would call the
exhale part of being a coach or my past
work was with executives and leaders and
folks who their job is taking care of
other people which is what you do yeah
well it's something that's making you
nervous now that's making you a fool no
man it's exhausting me helping to show
up and make certain that I'm present for
them when I to have to make certain my
household personal economy and all those
things are okay
and so just knowing that I can be
present and not overwork myself which I
I think I did in the beginning like in
that first month I was like oh let me
meet the me let me be out there let's
have a zoom call let me do all the
newsletters and all the things to be
present for my community and then one
day I just it was a Thursday night I do
and I said whoa okay maybe this is the
day I need to take off personal
self-care okay yeah self-care is the
magic moment it's about to get really
heavy so we'll see you next
video we're gonna leave you on a
cliffhanger this is like this is fun for
me I always want to be a movie star and
it didn't work so here we are so come
back and see us again thank you so much
for being here next video we're going to
talk about self-care how to take care of
yourself secondary traumatic stress and
that feeling when you're called upon to
help everybody else in your community
that can weigh you down too dr. John
DeLong the Ramsey Network subscribe
punch all the buttons and the tubes and
I will see you soon take care